is the system of linear equations below
dependent or independent and they give
us two equations right here and before i
tackle this specific problem let's just
do a little bit of review of what
dependent or independent means and
actually i'll compare that to consistent
and inconsistent
so just to start off with if we're
dealing with systems of linear equations
in two dimensions there's only three
possibilities that these that the lines
or the equations can have relative to
each other so let me draw the three
possibilities so let me draw three
coordinate axes
so that's my first axis x-axis and
y-axis
so x and y let me draw another one
and that is x
and that is
y let me draw one more because there's
only three possibilities in two
dimensions
x and y for dealing with linear
equations
x
and y
so you can have the situation where the
lines just intersect in one point
let me do this in so you could have
one line like that and maybe the other
line does something like that and they
intersect at one point you could have
the situation where the two lines are
parallel so you could have a situation
actually let me draw it over here
where you have one line that goes like
that and then the other line has the
same slope but it's shifted it has a
different y-intercept so maybe it looks
like this and you have no points of
intersection and then you could have the
situation
where
they're actually the same line so that
both lines have the same slope and the
same y-intercept so really they are the
same line they intersect on an infinite
number of points every point on either
of those lines is also point on the
other line
so just to give you a little bit of the
terminology here
and we learned this in the last video
this type of
this type of system where they don't
intersect where you have no solutions
this is an inconsistent
inconsistent system
inconsistent system and by definition or
i guess just taking the opposite of
inconsistent both of these would be
considered consistent
both of these are consistent
but then within consistent there's
obviously a difference here we only have
one solution these are two different
lines that intersect in one place and
here they're essentially the same exact
line and so we differentiate between
these two scenarios by calling this one
over here independent
independent
and this one over here dependent
dependent so independent both lines are
doing their same their own thing they're
not they're not dependent on each other
they're not the same line they will
intersect at one place dependent they're
the exact same line any point that
satisfies one line will satisfy the
other any point that satisfies one
equation will satisfy the other so with
that said let's see if this system this
linear the system of linear equations
right here is dependent or independent
so they're kind of having us assume that
it's going to be consistent that we're
either going to intersect in one place
we're going to intersect in an infinite
number of places
and the easiest way to do this we
already have this second equation here
it's already in slope intercept form we
had we know the slope is negative 2 the
y intercept is 8. let's put this first
equation let's put this first equation
up here in slope intercept form and see
if it has a different slope or a
different intercept or maybe it's the
same line
so we have 4x plus 2y
is equal to 16.
we can subtract 4x from both sides what
we want to do is isolate the y on the
left hand side
so let's subtract 4x from both sides
the left-hand side we are just left with
a 2y and then the right-hand side we
have a negative
4x plus 16. i just wrote the negative 4
in front of the 16 just so that we have
it in the traditional slope intercept
form and now we can divide both sides of
this equation by 2 so that we can
isolate the y on the left hand side
divide both sides by 2 we are left with
y is equal to negative 4 divided by 2 is
negative 2
x plus 16 over 2 plus 8. so all i did is
algebraically manipulated this top
equation up here and when i did that
when i solved essentially 4y
i got this right over here which is the
exact same thing as the second equation
we have the exact same slope negative 2
negative 2 and we have the exact same
y-intercept 8 and 8. if i were to graph
these equations
if i were to graph these equations
that's my x-axis
and that is my
y-axis
both of them have a y-intercept at 8 and
then have a slope of negative 2. so they
look something i'm just drawing an
approximation of it but they look
something they would look something like
that so maybe this is the graph of this
equation right here this first equation
and the second equation will be the
exact same graph it has the exact same
y-intercept and the exact same slope so
clearly these two lines are dependent
dependent
they have an infinite number of points
that are common to both of them because
they're the same
line